all right so what can I say about the
flash
it's that show that I look forward to
every week know that in catfish
marathons mostly flash the flash season
two and to let you know this is going to
be spoiler free to a point about half
this videos gonna be spoiler free then
I'm gonna say spoiler warnings gonna be
huge thing you will know when the
spoilers are coming they might talk
about some spoilers for people who did
see season two a flash over now you're
good you're safe but I'll let you know
when you have to you know click off if
you haven't seen season two the flash I
don't let you guys know I'm not gonna
talk about every beat for beat thing
that happens in the 23 episodes of flash
staging - I'm generally gonna tell you
what I liked and what stuck out for me
and what might be coming next season and
then there you go that's a video that's
what I do I talk about [ __ ] so the flash
season 2 starts out not where season one
left off no starts out six months after
season one which I found kind of jarring
but you quickly get over that when you
find your stride and you're going along
with the show so in the end of last
season we saw the helmet of Jay Garrick
pop out of that portal reverse flash is
like that's my cue to leave and now we
see Jay Garrick and this dude I saw
Moe's like that guy is a superhero you
seem he just looks like you'd be like
hey citizens haha it's a pretty good day
here in the city I'm gonna go help that
old lady cross the street haha my
hang-up with the guy was like pretty
young to be Jay Garrick Jay Garrick I
would see as older but you want to
appeal to the young fans of the flash so
okay I got you marketing more on that
later but that portal that opened up
ultimately opened up a bunch of portals
to earth-2 and there are a lot more
baddies in earth too that are coming
over here because the bad guy his name
is zoom and he's evil and super fast one
of the first things he does in the first
few episodes of the show he gets flash
and just starts kicking the [ __ ] out of
him brings him around to all the news
outlets and he's like here's jock starts
just beating the [ __ ] out of the flash I
mean the concept is if people can see
their protector or God bleed then they
won't have faith in him anymore prabha
kind of work zoom is fast manzou is fast
& zoom is bad news let me get Harrison
wells back if you saw season one of the
flash which I hope you did Harrison
wells is not around anymore so now we
have
other Harrison wells this Harrison wells
I didn't like as much as Eagle barbed
thorn posing as Harrison wells this
Wells kind of had a chip on his shoulder
he was a bit more of a dick eel Barth on
it's really funny I'm saying this guy's
a dick not as much as the reverse-flash
reverse-flash was a murderous [ __ ]
but he would say he had a charisma to
him and he was actually a cool dude do
you feel like you can hang out with him
like everything else get a beer or
something yeah oh that old Nora Allen
thing well you know we all have her [ __ ]
zooms keeping a man in an iron mask in a
cage the only thing in a cage with
reverse-flash was Grodd he was
remarkably nice to him the point is I
was glad to get Harrison wells back
because I liked the actor and I just
think I want to see the guy on screen
zoom was perfect for season 2 of the
flash season 1 it was a very personal
story so when you're done with the
personal story who you gonna bring in
now well you're gonna bring in someone
who was an [ __ ] who is just faster
than flash or reverse flash and bring in
another youniverse because I love it
when they go to that universe and you
see see things that are different some
people they're just like Barry Allen
over there is kind of a wimp it's just
fascinating to me I love the kind of
stuff and we get Wally West in this
season if you guys didn't know who ollie
West is he is one of the Flash's will he
become a flash will he not I don't know
at first I was I was kind of resistant I
was like who are you
you're Wally West I don't know you're
actually willy West I actually end up
like in the kid that's the thing about
the flash is that the supporting cast
you really gravitate to you like them
you want to hang out with these guys and
it being earth-2 you see a lot of evil
versions of the friends that we have on
this slide and earth-2 they're kind of
dicks I'm keeping it vague because I
can't talk about season two of the
Flash's in depth as I want to without
spoilers so that is your spoiler warning
man it's going to go down basically in
short flash season 2 was great not as
good as season 1 for me because I love
reverse flash and flash stuff but hey go
watch flash come back we're gonna talk
about how good this season actually is
with these spoilers get-go and if you
haven't seen flash yet please stop the
video I'll give you a second that's not
the stop button that's the pot all right
okay I assume your gun spoilers coming
now Johnny generic good guy who actually
irritated me because he's low I'm Jay
Garrick but I don't have any speed zoom
took my powers
hmm he's a bad guy so he's hitting on
Caitlin snow they
tire time your leg what do you why bring
in Jay Garrick to not have him do any
Jay Garrick ISM so then at a point zoom
takes off his mask you're like holy [ __ ]
that's him like Jay Garrick's the bad
guy there's a big part of me I was like
wait a minute that or was it like a
rewrite where's like I don't shoot I
think he's kind of irrelevant all right
we're gonna make him the bad guy now saw
interviews and they swear it was planned
from the beginning to make Jay Garrick
hunter zolomon who is zoom so Jay
Garrick isn't actually Jay Garrick he's
hunter zolomon he is zoom he's the bad
guy he wants flashes power he wants his
speed so he can be even faster done
thing his flash gives it up to him at a
point even Superman is Superman to
actually faked him out and then crushes
odds hand and Froome down the PIP thing
and no one ever cared that he actually
murdered Zod in that movie but then
flash gets his powers back because
Harrison wells tries to give him his
powers back and then some vaporizing
Barry Allen Barry Allen goes into the
Speed Force with the Speed Force is
ultimately sentient and it's talking to
him it was actually a good episode for
Barry Allen's character but this is like
there are two episodes left after this
episode and we're doing this la-dee-da
flashes in the Speed Force thing now
gonna go for that in episode 15 or 16 or
something it was they were directed by
Kevin Smith which is great I like seeing
the fact that Kevin Smith got to direct
the flash since he you know cried in the
finale of the first season that's
awesome I'm just saying with two
episodes left you got to get down to it
man let's see some zoom stuff but I
really liked when zoom got taken down
because I guess there are time rights
when you breach time which zoom has done
and there's another time-traveling
episode where Barry Allen did it there
are time wraiths that come after you
they just ended up getting hunter
zolomon and ripping his mask a bit and
then he looked like a zombie he looked
like black lantern zoom which is pretty
cool but he's not dead
so he could come back long story short
he gets taken away and Barry Allen made
a speed duplicate of himself and one of
them will be there both him and one of
them died in order to save everybody's
which kind of shows like Oh Barry Allen
would straight-up give his life we all
knew that about him but now they know
that about him it's finally the identity
of the man in the iron mask I fear I
mean we all knew it was Jay Garrick the
actual Jay Garrick that there was no
doubt about that
but who was Jay Garrick and I was like
I'll bet you it's his dad from the other
earth and his dad was like that's my
grandma's maiden name and then hunter
zolomon zoom just punches Barry Allen's
dad through the chest and kills and I
was like is Jay Garrick's gonna be his
dad from the other side straight up and
it was which was really cool oh yeah
it's older Jay Garrick that makes more
sense so the end of the season I was
like I enjoyed it I liked it I liked the
end but it's not season one end man
season one straight-up had me in tears
it was a great finale so iris and Barry
Allen are talking and then the end Barry
Allen sitting around and then he's just
like screw this noise and he just hauls
ass breaches time goes back to when his
mother was murdered and just kicks the
[ __ ] out of reverse-flash she's like
you're not gonna hurt them ever again
just basically living piss out of this
guy tells his mom he's like don't worry
no one will ever hurt you and it was
when Barry was doing this Barry was
saving his mom that I was met with that
feeling man the man tears started coming
on I was like good for you dude do it
save your mom save your dad save your
family you deserve it and then you see
Barry Allen from the indices and one
remember season 1 he goes back and then
the flash was like yeah don't do it then
so Barry Allen didn't save his mom Barry
Allen from season 1 looks at his mom he
says like oh she's safe and he
disappears just like that time is
different times they are a-changin which
makes you think one thing flash boy I
want to be vague about flashpoint in
case you haven't read it or seen the
animation but basically Barry's mom
didn't die and so now Barry Allen has
all the memories of what happened when
she did die in him becoming the flash
but he never became the flash because
his mom never died he did so everything
is different but it is a worse world and
that is straight-up what it's gonna be
it's funny i see people in social media
like Barry Allen was selfish II just
screwed the timeline he screwed
everything up cuz he's a douche all
right let's see if they're his point of
view though we know he screwed it up
because we're here and if he didn't
screw it up they wouldn't really have a
show so we know it's gonna be bad news
but he doesn't know that do you have
that one thing that thing in your
childhood past I don't know a death of a
friend death of a parent something bad
that happened that if you could go back
in time and change it you would or that
means you would do exactly what Barry
did so Barry Allen changes time I'm
excited yet I'm kind of worried I'm
straight-up excited for what they can do
first of all we know that Supergirl has
come to the CW now so it could be all
right his mom never died he goes back
things are different hey there's this
Supergirl now so in the end when he
changes it all back
the world's going to still be out in
flashpoint the [ __ ] this is a spoiler
for flashpoint here we are he changes it
back and in the end things some things
remained slightly different and that was
DC's way of doing the DC reboot new 52
the ability to have a different universe
that when you change it back will still
have some remnants that stick around is
a perfect way to have Supergirl come to
the CW now and think about the things
that they could do I mean the world
where Barry Allen never showed Oliver
Queen that being a beacon of hope is
actually better than being a dick Oliver
Queen will still be a dick in fact Barry
Allen was never around to help him out
of that whole season three thing so
maybe racial ghouls reckon the world now
Rochelle ghoul otherwise it's known as
Oliver Queen maybe that'll happen one
thing I know for sure you our thumb is
still around I'm pumped about that I
like you Barth I'm so I love the fact
it's like no he's beaten up he's taken
away somewhere but he's still around and
we will get our third Harrison wells
I think the first Harrison wells was ela
Barth aunties and - Harrison wells was
earth - Harrison wells season 3 Harrison
wells will be Harrison wells from a
timeline where the reverse-flash never
killed them three seasons three Harrison
wells is and maybe Wally West will be
the flash in this reality maybe you know
you'll see like the flash street just
BAM he's like whoa I'm not the flash
what's this since Wally West is the
flash but I am a little worried in the
sense that I used to watch fringe and I
remember the episode were Peter Bishop
in the season finale of one of the
seasons just got blinked out of
existence he never existed and the whole
time he was gone I was like all right
come on bring him back already let's get
this show on the road so they finally
brought him back but I don't want to
feel like that with the flash the whole
time flash doesn't have his powers I
don't want to be like oh come on get
your powers back get your powers back
and then finally he does I mean granted
Barry Allen will still be around so
won't actually be the same thing I'm
just saying it makes a guy nervous it's
also I don't know if this whole Barry's
mom's alive flashpoint universe thing is
going to go on just for a few episodes
or if they're gonna commit and have a go
the whole season or it's gonna be
wrapped up at the beginning after they
solved it six months prior either case
I'm looking forward to it because that's
just it's interesting they could do a
lot of stuff they can make good people
bad I want to see Oliver Queen be an
[ __ ] I don't know why I just did the
coolest version of Laurel as I ever saw
was this season of flash when she was
from Earth two guys in the end the flash
season 2 was great I like season 1 more
than two that's my personal preference
but it's still it's a show seasons 1
into watch them marathon I'm live on
love them it's a great superhero show
they always have great villains they
always bring it the one thing is there
are always filler episodes throughout
because it's 23 episodes longer season
they could cut some of those out make it
tighter I'm looking forward for what
they do in season 3 the possibilities
are ahead of them I hope they do it the
way they should do it I'm not saying I
even know what they should do I'm just
saying just flashpoint that's awesome
right guys so the flash season 2 have
you seen it what did you think about it
or what do you want to see in the flash
season 3 let's start theorizing here
this is YouTube after all so whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more